♪ ♪ ♪
- Paul-Émile Borduas,
on le connaît comme peintre,
chef de fil des automatistes
et rédacteur du manifeste
du "Refus global"...
- Rachel, je suis malade.
- Mais c'est comme amoureux
de Rachel Laforest
qu'on le redécouvre
à l'Espace Go dans
"J'ai cru vous voir".
JEAN-FRANÇOIS CASABONNE,
comédien
- Quand Paul-Émile voyait Rachel
poser ses yeux sur ses toiles,
on aurait dit que ses toiles
se mettaient à vivre.
- Elle avait clairement les yeux
plus foncés que ça.
- Durant près d'une décennie,
les deux amants ont entretenus
une relation épistolaire
secrète.
PASCALE BUSSIÈRE, comédienne
- Ça a été un amour presque
sans chair, c'est un amour
platonique, mais un amour
qui s'est nourri
par la littérature,
par l'écriture,
par l'échange d'idées.
- Dans ce coffre, tu trouveras
quelque chose de moi...
- À la mort de Rachel Laforest,
leur amour et leur
correspondance a été révélée.
Une surprise pour le fils
de Rachel qui a ensuite publié
les lettres dans le recueil
"Aller jusqu'au bout des mots".
ALEXIA BÜRGER, Adaptation,
dramaturgie et mise en scène
- C'est tout d'un coup
plein de facettes méconnues
d'une femme qu'il connaissait
très bien qui ont été révélées,
et c'est ce que fait l'amour,
je trouve, c'est ce que fait
aussi la mort, au sens
plus large, c'est-à-dire
que quand les gens meurent,
on découvre d'eux des choses
qu'on n'avait pas vues.
- Sans avoir été signataires
du manifeste du "Refus global",
Rachel Laforest et son mari
de l'époque évoluaient
en marge du mouvement.
- Elle a quand même été
une espèce d'électron libre
autour de cette mouvance-là,
Rachel. Elle avait une pensée
très moderne pour l'époque.
- Cette correspondance
m'était indispensable.
- La pièce "J'ai cru vous voir",
entrelace aux lettres
des amoureux, un dialogue
avec des philosophes.
JOSEPH MARCHAND, musicien,
compositeur et comédien
- C'est de partir
de ces correspondances-là et
de les amener à ce niveau-là
à se questionner sur l'amour,
l'idée de l'autre, la projection
de l'autre, ce qu'on fait
de l'autre dans notre tête.
- Qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand
on ne vit pas une histoire
d'amour au quotidien?
On se permet d'inventer l'autre
puis de le créer, finalement.
- La pandémie avait forcé
le report de la pièce,
mais l'amour triomphe
enfin sur scène.
- C'est ça, l'amour!
Il faut éprouver le désir
pour que les choses naissent
par le coeur fait que là,
je pense que la pandémie a fait
naître des choses du coeur.
- Mais comment faire sans jamais
pouvoir vous rejoindre!
- "J'ai cru vous voir" est
à l'affiche de l'Espace Go.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.